Counter-Strike 2 is here and the
game has changed valve's first look at
the game which is set to launch this
summer shows some big changes including
smokes the shape of the smoke cloud can
be pushed and carved by bullets and
grenades
and yeah you'll get to keep your skins
and they might look even better the much
anticipated Improvement to server tick
rate is real too they're calling the
solution subtic updates basically for
most things they say tick rate won't
matter and the server will calculate
your precise actions between ticks
so what you see is what you get and your
favorite maps are still there along with
some new ones and boy do they look
amazing so how do you get into
The Limited Test just log into CS go and
if you're lucky You've Got a
notification inviting you good luck